[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا مشاهدينا الكرام الى فقره
وجها لوجه فيها نبحث في مدى خطوره
التغيرات المناخيه التي تشهدها الدول
المغربيه ومدى التزام هذه الدول بدعم
الجهود الدوليه
المسببه للاحتباس الحراري كما نسال عما
اذا كانت قضايا المناخ بالنسبه للشعوب
المغاربيه
وحكوماتها فعلا اولويه
من تونس العاصمه السيد حمدي حشاد المهندس
البيئي والمختصر
المناخي سيد حمدي
شكرا جزيلا لك على تربيه الدعوه
شكرا لك مرحبا كل الترحيب مرحبا انت ايضا
كل الترحيب بضيفي في الجانب المقابل من
الدار البيضاء الدكتور محمد سعيد قروق
استاذ علم المناخ بجامعه الحسنه ثاني
بالدار البيضاء دكتور محمد سعيد خروب اهلا
بك ومرحبا وشكرا جزيلا لك ايضا على تلبيه
هذه الدعوه
الكرام على تلفزيون
الى اي ماده تتاثر الدول المغاربيه
بالتغيرات المناخيه وما هي الاشكالات التي
تعاني منها على وجه الخصوص هل التغيرات
المناخيه التي تواجهها الدول الصناعيه
الكبرى والمتقدمه هي نفسها التي تواجهها
اليوم الدول المغاربيه ام انه ربما فمتى
اشكالات خاصه دكتور بالمنطقه المغاربيه
هي نفس التحديات الطبيعيه التي تفرض على
الجميع الا انها خصوصيات منطقه صناعه
تتميز بالقرار على طول السنه وهذا شيء مهم
جدا
وبالتالي نحن عرضه للجفاف بطريقه قاعديه
وبندق
كذلك صعوبات اكثر من الدول الموجوده في
الدقه الاخرى من البحر الابيض المتوسط
بذلك اوروبا
همم اكثر اهميه مما يمكن ان يكون الا ان
نحن زكريا في نموذج امل طويل
من الدول الموجوده في الشرق الابيض
المتوسط
المناخي البلدان المغاربيه تساهم بنسب
ضئيله في الاحتباس الحراري ولكن الى اي
مدى هي فعلا متضرره من التغيرات المناخيه
الناجمه همم عنه وفي ايه مجالات تحديدا من
وجهه نظرك هل ربما فما اشكالات خاصه
بالمنطقه المغربيه دون عن غيرها حتى نتحدث
عن تشخيص اول
حقيقه ااه الدول المغرب العربي بصدد
معايشه مشهد سريالي للغايه في ما يخص
التغيرات المناخيه نحن تقريبا باستثناء
ذوبان الجليد نحن تقريبا جمعنا كل الظواهر
المناخيه العنيفه التي تحدث على مستوى
العالم
لنا منها نصيب يعني سيبها في المغرب او
الجزائر او تونس او ليبيا او موريتانيا
سواء بارتفاع منسوب مياه البحر او موجات
الجفاف المتكرره او الامطار الطوفانيه
التي تحصل من حين الى اخر هذه كلها تقريبا
مشاهد تتكرر من اوينا الى اخرى في مناطقنا
تقريبا الحجم الاقتصادي لدول المغرب
العربي ليس بكبير واا اسهامات التاريخيه
ومسؤوليتها التاريخيه في انبعاثات همم
غازات الاحتباس الحراري
لكن مع ذلك لو همم تحدثنا على كل
الاشكاليات الاقتصاديه وما خلفته من همم
اشكاليه اجتماعيه او سياسيه تكون تغيرات
مناخيه همم حاضره على اكثر من مستوى
بالنسبه لاسباب العميقه لهذه المشاكل يعني
لو اخذنا على العين الاعتبار نحن مجتمعات
فلاحيه بالاساس لو تتضرر بالفلاحه نظريا
للنظره الامطار او التكرر المواسم الجفاف
او همم لفقره التربه المرتبط في كذلك همم
وحده من اشكال ثانويه التغيرات المناخيه
هذا كله له جمعناها ستجد ان التركيب
الفلاحي لهذه الدول تتضرر او المجتمعات
الفلاحيه تتضرر باشكاله باخرى وتشكل همم
وقود لي ظواهر اخرى القوارب الموت التي
تشق البحر الابيض المتوسط من الضفه
الجنوبيه نحو الضفه الشماليه واحده من
اسبابها العميقه هي ان هي الانظمه الانتاج
الفلاحي في تلك المناطق وسناتي ربما لاحقا
على تداعيات تحديدا في هذا السياق وعلى
مساله الوعي المجتمعي
بقضايا همم التغير
المناخي همم جفاف تصحر ضعف لخشوبه التربه
فيضانات الى غير ذلك والقائمه طويله
بالنسبه للمنطقه همم المغاربيه عدد ذوبان
الجديد كما ذكرت سيد حمدي حشاد ولكن همم
المشاركه ايضا رفيعه همم في همم
القمم قمم المناخ همم المشاركه كانت رفيعه
المستوى لدول المغاربيه في قمه كوب 27 في
شرم الشيخ وهنا اود ان اسال ضيف السيد
محمد همم سعيد همم قروق هل هذه المشاركه
رفيعه المستوى حتى على مستوى رؤساء الدول
المغاربيه هل تعكس فعلا اراده سياسيه للحد
من التغيرات المناخيه اراده سياسيه من
الدول المغاربيه للحد من هذه التغيرات
والتكيف معها دكتور
انا متاكد من هذه الاراده السياسه منذ
طويل بالمناسبه قد تذكر انه هو منذ سنه
2000 كان لدينا برنامج مشترك بين الدول
المغاربيه ثلاث جزائر المغرب وتونس وحولها
وقدمنا تقارير متعدده من الناحيه العلميه
ومن ناحيه كذلك الاداريه
بالمغرب مراكش
من القرار الافريقيه بطريقه مباشره وطريقه
الحال الدول المغاربيه اليوم
الشيخ همم اعرف ان ال- همم
التمثيري هي المغربيه
كثيفه في هذا اللقاء همم اكيد ان كذلك همم
صدور
الجيران لكن الجزائر ولا تونس يكونوا في
نفس همم بنفس همم
طيب الجزائر
بالنسبه لتونس برئاسه الوزراء السيده
نجلاء همم بودن وسيد محمد النفي عن ليبيا
بمعنى ان ثمه همم تمثيل رفيع المستوى همم
رئيس المجلس همم الرئاسي بعض الاطراف ايه
يعني
المستوى ايضا همم افرح عليك سؤال سيد حمدي
حداد المهندس البيئي والمختص في شان
المناخي بعض الاطراف لاحظنا بدات منشغله
اكثر خلال هذه القمه قمه كوب 27 وحتى
القمم السابقه باللقاءات الجانبيه
والعلاقات الدبلوماسيه هنا اطرح عليك سؤال
مشاركه الدول المغاربيه رفيعه المستوى
التي لاحظناها من وجهه نظرك انت هل تنم
جوهريا عن التزام هذه الدول الفعلي تجاه
قضايا المناخ
سيدي مجرد الحضور في نزل خمسه نجوم وقضاء
يومين فيه لا يعني امتلاكه بالضروره هذا
ما يحدث في كل مره يعني من لا يكفي مجرد
حضور رفيع المستوى لحل هذه الاشكاليات
يعني تقريبا هذه مجاملات دبلوماسيه تحدث
من قمه الى اخرى تحدث في خلال التظاهرات
الدوليه لكن ما بقياس مدى الالتزام يخدع
الى عديد المعايير وهمم والمقاييس التي
ممكن ان نقيم بها مد الالتزام تلك الدوله
او ذلك النظام دون غيره لكن دائما نشخص
الامر على شاكلته يعني بدون مكياج سياسي
او بدون تحسين للصوره النمطيه التي اعتدنا
الترويج لها نحن ندقا فن المركزي السياسي
يعني مجمد سياساتنا نعطيها احجام اكبر من
اعجامها هذا ما يحدث الان تقريبا في
حالتنا على خلف الدول المغرب العربي
تقريبا هناك العديد من الالتزامات وهناك
لو تتبعنا مسائل التزامات والتعهدات وماذا
صرح به زعماءنا وقادتنا منذ فترات
منذ بدايه القيمه الماليه وما مدى وقع
تحقيقها على ارض الواقع ولو وقع نقده
بموضوعيه سنكون هناك شتان بين متعهد ما
تعهدوا بهم بينما هو موجود على ارض الواقع
يعني هناك انفصام كبير هناك نعم بعض
الانجازات هناك بعض السياسات تطبيقات لكن
لا ترتقي الى مستوى انجازات نتباهى بها
امام العديد من الامم التي تمتلك النفس
لامكانيات والقدرات التقنيه والاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه نحن تقريبا همم نحن همم
نهدروا في الفرص تقريبا في كل مره نادر في
فلسطين نحن نهضر في الفرص ان كنا متجمعين
ونطبق سياسات موحده اقليميه ما بين هذه
الدول بالتجاوز على الاقل او مائيا لانه
هذا تقريبا محاور كبره التي العمل عليها
لكن الان هناك لو جمعنا كل الحاله اعلام
تقريبا نحن ضد صناعه قصص نجاح في مستوى
سياسه المناخيه هي مجرد خطط قصيره المدى
يق تطبيقه ثم بعد يقع استغلالها في ماركه
تيم سياسي يعني ليس لا يعني حضور قاد او
زعماء من مستوى رفيع يعني اننا ملتزمون
هذا مقياس خاطئ ولا همم لا يعتمد لماذا
لقياس مستوى نجاح هذه الدوله او تلك طيب
هل النتائج فعلا
الدكتور محمد سعيد خروق استاذ علي المناخ
في جامعه الحسن الثاني بالدار البيضاء بعد
اتفاق باريس وميثاق جلاسكو وكل القيمه
الاخرى كما ذكرته التي حتى ظنها المغرب من
وجهه نظرك انت هل نجحت الدول المغاربيه في
اعتماد مسارات تنمويه صديقه للبيئه تتوجه
نحو الطاقات النظيفه والبديله هل نجحت في
وضع اليات لمواجهه اثار الاحتباس الحراري
ام ان ربما كل ما في الامر مجاملات
دبلوماسيه لا اكثر واهدار الفرس كما يقول
رغيفي دكتور
لكي اوجوب على
التساؤلاتكم
يعني الملف واشكاليه ضخمه جدا
والملف وعباره عن مشكله
ونحاول ان نجد حلولا لهم الناحيه السياسيه
والاقتصاديه هذا العمليه هي سابقه في
السياسه العالميه وفي الاجتهادات
من لا يعرف ان في المغرب
لدينا سياسات الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
لم يكن احد يتكلم عن التحول المناخيه
همم توبي عدسه السياسه بعد قمه وحرب 1992
ريال وحينما تم الاتفاق على التقاط قياده
العالميه حول المنافق وبالتالي اليوم
الحمد لله نحن اا نتوفر على الثرسانه من
السدود نفتخر بها يجب ان اطول الاشياء كما
هي لاننا استطعنا ان نعبي اكثر من 16
مليار متعب من المياه
ضخم جدا ونحاوله ان نتابعه هذه السياسه
المرتبطه
على التجربه المغاربيه ايضا بشكل عام من
وجهه نظرك وهل اسفلت هذه القمم فعلا على
همم تغيير
الامور وهل تم استراتيجيه واضحه الان
اليوم من قبل الدول المغاربيه نحن التقلنا
لبعض يقول انه يجب ان ننتقل من مرحله
التفاوض الى مرحله هل وصلنا الى هذه
المرحله همم على الصعيد المغاربي مع
الاساتذه المتوفق في ذلك لان هناك خلافات
سياسيه بين بين هذه البلدان التي تعرقي
هذا النوع من التفكير وهذا النوع من العمل
وهذا مؤسيفا لكن يهمني ان اقول بان اعرف
كثيرا الاشياء صح الظروف في تونس عبر
اصدقائي اباحيتين في هذا الميزان
الذي يقدمونهم قليل منها اعرفها على همم
على الجزائر هذا لا يعني انها غير موجوده
لانها عرفت قليل منها لان الباحثين في هذه
الميدان قبائل كذلك في الجزائر
ونحن في المغرب اكثر اهميه من هدف الانتاج
العلمي المتخصص في هذا الميزان
دي همم بلدان يعني المغرب وتونس همم تطورت
في لاحدتها ولا يمكن ان نصور الفلاحه
عمليه توفي لما هي عمليه لماذا داخل
الاحترار الارضي وداخل المشاكل المرتبطه
بالدوره المائيه العامه التي تعرفه خلخله
ضخمه منذ ان ارتفعت درجات الحراره الان
والصلاه الى درجه كامله فصيله واحده محرم
وهذا له اثار سيئه مع الاسف نحن نحاولنا
وتوفقنا في جزء كبير من محاولات
والغداء والفيضانات
والطاقه الى اخره ولدينا مستقبل امامنا هو
همم
يبشر بالخير بالخير
الامم المتحده هذا اليوم بشان المناخ
اطلقه خطه عالميه تسعى الى جمع ما يصل الى
ثلاث مئه مليار دولار في العام من مستثمري
القطاعين الخاص والعام مساعده المجتمعات
الاشد فقرا في العالم على الصمود في
مواجهه اثار الاحتباس الحراري اتحدث عن
المنطقه المغاربيه هل التمويلات اللازمه
للانتقال البيئي للانتقال المناخي في
الدول المغاربيه موجوده
وكافيه همم حتى منها بل تحديدا من الدول
المتقدمه الصناعيه الكبرى
الصالحين على الاقل في همم الموضوع همم
امكانيات الدول المغاربيه واحده لوحدها لا
تكفي لانتقال اقتصادي النجاح همم نموذج
يكون صديق للمناخ نحن بحاجه الى دعم مالي
وتقني وكذلك مرافقه لتطبيق بعض السياسات
او بعض البرامج لكن بعض التعاضديه او بعض
الدول التي تعهدت بمبالغ ماليه تقريبا منذ
اتفاقيه باريس الى حدود الان هناك تقصير
هناك فشل في تجميعه هذه الاموال تقريبا
هناك عجز سنوي بتعهدات معنى كانت المفروض
تكون في المستوى 100 مليار كل سنه وهنا
هناك تقريبا الان تعبئه في حدود 83 مليار
دولار يعني هناك عاجز في هذه الموازنه في
هذه التعاودات هناك كذلك همم محور كيفيه
التصرف في هذه الاموال او المحاور التي
المفروض ان تتوجهها اليها هذه الدعم كذلك
يجب لا ننسى ان بعض هذه الوعود هي سابقه
الى اوانها هذه الوعود انج قبل ان يكون
همم الازمه الاوكرانيه او ازمه الطاقه
الروسيه يعني هناك العديد من الدول
التعاهدت في مرحله في منح هذه التمويلات
وهذه همم هذا الدعم المالي لكن الان هي
تواجه مازق حقيقي نظرا لانها الان في ازمه
ثقيله يعني هي في نفسها
عارفه كما تمن دخل علينا في الخط هناك
ستسمحك في ان تسترسل سيد حمدي حجاج
من تعهد عن هناك بعض الدول لهذه تخلت على
بعض
خططتها معناها لان نحو انتقال تقي نظيف او
طاقات تكون صديقه المناخه على مصر والا
امبارح
الصوره نمطيه الان قبل ان نمر على المباشر
كنت بسدد قراءه اليابان اجلت ضريبه
الكربون مثلا هذه كانت
وضع هذه الضريبه للتمويل بعض السياسات
المناخيه سواء داخل اليابان او خارجها
يعني تقريبا دول الكبرى واقتصاديه اللي هي
المحركات او كذلك حتى بعض الشركات الكبرى
هي المحركات لهذه التمويلات هي تتواجد
اقتصادي يعني هناك تعهدت نعم لكن يجب ان
لا تكون تعودات همم
طموحاتنا وتوقعاتنا من هذه المطلب طيب
محمد سعيد قاروق استاذ علي المناخ في
جامعه الحسن الثاني بالدار ده همم ربما
بالاكيد انك همم تابعت هذه الخطه خطه قمه
المناخذه اليوم بثلاث همم 100 مليار
تقريبا همم هل هي حاسمه فعلا من وجهه نظرك
هل سيتم الايفاء بها هل الوفاء الايفاء
بالتزامات تمويل العمل المناخي من الدول
المتقدمه للبلدان الناميه من بينها ربما
البلدان المغاربيه ايضا هذا هل هذا الامر
مضمون من وجهه همم نظرك سيد
همم
اسباني
ولكن مع الاساتذه
اسباب متعدده هذه همم
زلمه همم اليوم كان حرب اوكرانيا قبلها
كانت همم
وبالتالي همم يعود ملف المناقي الى الدرجه
الثانيه او ربما الثالثه
اييه يعني اختياري يعني من وقع عليها هو
اختياري ومن
تعهد بالتقرير من غازات او باي شيء اخر
يعني هو هو قرار اراضي فقط
لانه ليس لدينا صورته
وبالتالي هذه الاموال مع الاسف سينتظر
الفقراء ولكنها سوف بعد بعد
حديثنا عن همم الفقراء ايضا همم وهم كثر
في المجتمعات همم الناميه همم بحديثنا
ايضا عن مواطن الدول المغاربيه واسف منكم
ان الوقت ده امل باختصار شديد في الاجابه
على هذا السؤال الاخير همم من وجهه نظركما
هل تم تواعي كافا لدى
المواطنين في دول همم في الدول المغاربيه
هل المناخ ولويه بالنسبه لمواطنين الدول
المغاربيه بان صعوبه الواقع المعيشه اح لا
تجعل منه محل اهتمام حتى لا نقول اولويه
باختصار شديد حتى في اقل من 20 ثانيه سيد
حمدي حجاج وقت معك قبل ان اعطي الكلمه
الاخيره لسيدي
الممتاز في الامر ان التغيرات المناخيه
فرضت نوع من الصح والفكريه على المواطنين
دول المغاربيه الازمات المناخير المتكرره
العنيفه استفزت نوع الماء الوعي والادراك
والحب المعرفه لدى المواطن المغاربه التي
لا على هذا الموضوع والتعايش معه والتفهمه
هذا الامر تقريبا اعتبرهم ممتاز لانه هناك
باتت النوع من الثقافه المناخيه التي باتت
تنتشر طبقات همم لم تحاصل تعليم المستوى
التعليميه لكنها باتت على الاقل على توصيل
هذه المواضيع ابجديه
من شعوب المغاربيه بالمخاطر التي تتسبب
فيها تغيرات المناخيه في ديوانهم بسبب
تحديدا تداعيات هذه التغيرات على حياتهم
همم يوميه كما كان يقول ضيف وقت معك صلاح
عنيف التي عاش من طاقه وعزز هل الكره
الارضيه كامله
اصبحت اصبح عامه الناس يتكلمون عن التغيير
المناخي اكثر من السياسيين ارسم
اي ظاهره ظاهره لهم همم في التحول
المنافقين
وهذا همم وصل له عظمه الناس يعني الشعور
المغاربيه
التي خلفتها همم
وهذه هي الظواهر الكبرى التي تهمه
المغاربيه
والجفاف الحراره الماء ولكن كذلك الفيضان
على هذه الحلقه وعلى هذه الافاده جزيلا
شكرا من تونس العاصمه السيد حمدي حشاد
المهندس البيئي والمختص في شان المناخ وكل
الشكر جزيلا لك ايضا من الدار البيضاء
الدكتور محمد سعيد فاروق استاذ علم المناخ
في الحسن الثاني بالدار البيضاء كنتم معنا
في فقره وجها لوجه